Привет. Весь курс мы работали через директивы. На каждую задачу своя, запускаешь и получаешь результат.
Это была общая стартовая база. Простая, одинаковая для всех, чтобы каждый мог сдвинуться с места и не
собирать процесс с нуля. Сегодня мы делаем следующий шаг: берём всё, что накопилось за курс и
сворачиваем в твою собственную и среду. Такую, с которой дальше ты работаешь, как со своим
инструментом, индивидуально под тебя собранным. Директивы тут перестают быть отдельными файлами,
которые ты дёргаешь руками и становятся частью живого организма. А твоё отличие от других дальше не в
наборе директив, он у всех общий, а в том, как именно ты работаешь с агентом. Итак, сначала на пальцах,
из чего вообще состоит зрелая среда. Подробнее разберём чуть позже на уже собранной. Так нагляднее,
чем на словах. Если коротко, это три основных механизма: навыки, твои приёмы, которые агент
включает сам или же скиллы, субагенты — это отдельные исполнители под узкие задачи и
оркестрация. Правила, по которым главный агент всё это раздаёт. То есть, здесь у нас субагент под
одну задачу, под вторую, под третью. И основной главный агент раздаёт этим маленьким субагентам
их задачи, в зависимости от того, для чего эти там субагенты созданы. А правила, куда, кому и что он
отдаёт, как раз таки прописываются в оркестрации. И самый главный принцип сверху — это простота.
Антропик прямо рекомендует не усложнять без нужды, добавлять механику только тогда, когда она
реально улучшает результат. Поэтому среду мы собираем не по максимуму, а под то, как ты реально
работаешь. Мы знаем, что есть уже там готовые скиллы, готовые среды и так далее. Но, как правило,
они адаптированы под других людей и, соответственно, в твою среду принесут много лишнего, что не будет
задействоваться, либо будет скармливаться агенту просто тратить твое время без какого-либо
результата. Поэтому самый лучший способ, самый лучший флоу — это собирать агентские среды под
себя. И сегодня мы посмотрим, как это делать. И одно важное уточнение: как всё это должно быть
устроено, антропик постоянно пересматривает. Появляются новые возможности, меняются
рекомендации, что вообще считается хорошей средой, из чего она должна состоять и какие
методологии могут быть использованы. Твоя пересборка среды будет осуществляться также
через директиву. Если бы в неё я зашил структуру один раз, то она бы устарела довольно быстро.
Поэтому финальная директива сделана иначе: она при запуске сама смотрит в актуальную
документацию антропик и собирает среду по тому, как правильно прямо сейчас. Это не срез,
который один раз зафиксирован, а самая свежая и актуальная архитектура после выполнения этой
директивы. Итак, что вообще зашито в эту директиву? Давай по шагам. Чтобы ты понимал, что происходит,
а не просто смотрел в чёрный ящик. Сначала она читает актуальные доки
антропика, как сейчас устроены навыки,
субагенты, регистрация, возможно, какие-то ещё новые модули. Дальше, и это самое интересное,
она перелопачивает твою локальную историю работы. Все наши разговоры с агентом за курс
сохраняются прямо на твоём компьютере. Ты не можешь просто зайти в папку, открыть эти файлы,
почитать их. Они запрятаны достаточно глубоко и неудобно. Они нужны именно для клод кода, чтобы он их мог
подтягивать. То есть, если ты даже сейчас в другой аккаунт клода зайдёшь и откроешь свою среду, то те же
самые чаты у тебя там отразятся. Почему? Потому что они хранятся локально. Здесь как раз директива
называют поиск этих файлов, чатов, в котором огромное количество каких-то там ошибок, правок,
твоих собственных замечаний. Всё это опыт, который в дальнейшем позволит сформировать среду,
которая будет готова к полноценной работе. Исходя из этого, она собирает навыки, те же самые
скиллы, которые будут использоваться. Собирает оркестрацию и структуру. К этому моменту мы собрали уже
всё, сделали всё, что только можно. Теперь можно зафиксировать всю эту среду. Её структура сильно меняется,
не будет в ближайшее время. Ну, конечно, там уже что-то дальше придумаешь. Поэтому сейчас мы можем
это сделать. И после чего она архивирует старое и даёт сводку, чтобы ты понимал, как она вообще
устроена, из чего она состоит, что тут есть. Соответственно, среда строится не из головы,
а из того, как ты реально с ней работал. Если ты глубоко погружался, если давал ей много задач,
если не ленился её поправлять, всё это будет записано в память, в твои скиллы, и с этим ты пойдёшь дальше.
Итак, на этот раз директива называется «Release Environment». Перетягиваем и, как обычно, пишем:
«Запускай». Пока среда будет пересобираться, давай рассмотрим основные термины, которые тебе
точно пригодятся и которые ещё очень долго будут актуальны. Первое – это навык или скилл, то, что ты
наверняка уже слышал. Раньше, чтобы собрать экран, ты брал директиву и запускал её руками. Теперь это навык.
Ты просто ставишь агенту задачу, и он сам её узнаёт и поднимает нужный навык. И грузится навык,
только когда реально нужен. Поэтому их может быть много, а контекст не забивается. Второе – это
оркестрация. Это правило, по которым главный агент решает, что сделать самому, какой навык поднять,
и какому субагенту отдать там кусок той или иной задачи. Грубо говоря, его рабочая инструкция – как
себя вести в твоей среде. И третье – субагент отдельный исполнитель под узкую задачу. Прошерстить
какой-то большой проект, собрать данные – это уходит субагенту в его окно. И он возвращает только
результат, не засоряя основной разговор. А когда таких кусков несколько и они независимы,
их раздают сразу нескольким субагентам. И они работают параллельно, а это ещё и быстрее. По сути,
что такое агент в работе. Это не одна кнопка, а связка из главного агента, навыков, субагентов и
правил, по которым всё это крутится. Конкретным субагентам можно выделять конкретные навыки.
К некоторым навыкам можно давать доступ только к главному агенту. Для каких-нибудь исследований
можно запускать 10, 20, 30 субагентов, которые параллельно будут шерстить интернет. И вот,
что важно про то, как со всем этим работать. Тебе не нужно руками лезть в файлы, прописывать,
где какой навык лежит, как зарегистрировать субагента. Ты проговариваешь,
агенту, что хочешь видеть. Это внеси в отдельный навык. Вот это сделай через субагента. Здесь в
оркестрацию добавь такое правило и он выстраивает архитектуру сам. Поэтому главное для тебя не
заучить команды наизусть, а понимать принципы, чтобы ты понимал, как его направлять. Если ты владеешь
этой терминологией, знаешь, что такое оркестрация, субагенты, знаешь, что такое навыки,
оркестрация субагенты, ты просто ставишь задачу при формировании среды или там ее видоизменения
агенту и он сам автоматически делает это уже как нужно. Вот еще несколько таких лайфхаков,
фишек, которые тебе тоже нужно знать. Общие правила среды держи короткими. Это тот самый файлик
cloud.md, в котором записывается все самое основное, как среда работает. Если он больше 200 строк,
то все, уже там бесполезно все, что дальше идет, он начинает плохо работать. Держи cloud.md
меньше 200 строк. Обязательно обращай внимание, потому что он будет дополнять,
дополнять, дополнять его каждый раз, когда ты будешь его просить, не предупреждая тебя о том,
что там мой порог в 200 перешли. Второе, навык срабатывает по описанию, по нему агент понимает,
когда его поднять. Если навык не включается, когда ты этого ожидаешь, почти всегда дело в размытом
описании. Скажи агенту уточнить, что навык делает и когда применяется. Также используя такую
практику, как ключевые слова, насыщают этот навык какими-то ключевыми словами, там, например,
сверстать, компонент, токены и так далее. И он уже понимает, что этот скилл отсылает на дизайн
системе. И когда ты просишь его что-то выполнить, что используют там эти слова, он сразу это
подмечает, ага, мне нужен этот скилл. Третье, субагенты, это в первую очередь про параллель. Когда
работа дробится на независимые куски, когда работа делится на независимые куски, например,
прошерстить десяток разделов или проверить пять экранов, ты говоришь: раздай это субагентам. И они
идут одновременно, каждый в своем окне, а тебе возвращают итог. Так и быстрее, и основной твой разговор не
засоряется, его контекст тоже. Но делаем мы это только на независимых кусках, которые, там,
можно параллельно запустить. Линейную задачу, обычную, там, последовательную, субагент не
ускорит, а только добавит расход токенов и заставит дольше ждать. Так что все подряд через
субагентов мы не делаем. И тут же еще две оговорки: интерактив мы делаем основным агентом. То есть,
если тебе, например, фигма через МСП что-то нужно там поправить, субагент этого сделать не сможет. У
фигмы есть свое собственное ограничение, она просто его не впустит. Поэтому имей это в виду. И еще
одно уточнение: субагент не видит вашу переписку, так что все, что держится на твоих решениях из
разговора, либо проговаривай прямо в задаче, либо делай в основном контексте. Субагент - это такая более
глупая версия основного агента. Он берет одну маленькую задачу, выполняет ее и возвращает тебе
что-то. Он не для сложных, длинных процессов, он не для размышлений, не для сложных, длинных
процессов, а для такой, как бы более машинной работы. Итак, здесь директива отработала, он вывел мне,
что вообще теперь здесь создано. Итого у нас 27 навыков, 2 новых субагента,
оркестрация прописана в CloudMD, он переписан сейчас там 56 строк. Здесь уже у нас изложено,
что есть навыки, как они называются, к чему они относятся, есть субагенты,
что они делают. Краткая информация для того, чтобы агент, прежде чем приступать к какой-либо
задаче, понимал, куда ему идти, каким файлом обращаться. И также он заархивировал 27
директив, которые раньше у нас были. То есть, если нужно, можно их достать, но они в архиве и он
точно не будет им отдавать предпочтение и идти сверяться с ними. Вот можем посмотреть,
например, папка Cloud. В ней появилась папка Agents. Тут у нас есть Researcher, Screen Auditor. Он решил,
что двух субагентов будет достаточно. Один для Researcher, второй для аудита экранов. Также
скиллы. Вот здесь их 27 штук. Под сборку Storybook, под создание дизайн-системы и так далее. Здесь
все это изложено. Весь порядок действий тут включен. Здесь еще огромное количество папок. Под папок это не
не очень удобно. Я бы, например, здесь еще попросил создать еще один слой, в котором будут все артефакты,
которые там создаются в ходе работы с агентом, чтобы у меня все это было аккуратно свернуто.
Но здесь уже каждый делает, как ему удобнее. Ты волен как угодно выстраивать архитектуру своей среды. Главное,
не забывать, что есть методология Anthropic. Можешь также через агента к ней обращаться. Важно ее
придерживаться, чтобы у тебя наиболее оптимально работал агент, не тратил впустую токены,
время и возвращал хороший предсказуемый результат. Дальше эту среду ты растишь под себя. Появилась новая
повторяющаяся задача, заводишь под нее навык. Он начинает срабатывать сам. Нужен отдельный
исполнитель, добавляешь субагента и говоришь, когда его вызывать. Например, ты собрал панель для
своего продукта и под нее тебе нужны свои помощники. Один разбирает находки ютестов, другой следит за
консистентностью экранов, третий готовит данные. Говоришь это агенту, он заводит навык или субагента
и встраивает в оркестрацию. Среда подстраивается под твой продукт, а не наоборот. И это не только
про дизайн, те же кирпичики, навык, субагент, оркестрация. Можно навести и на то, чтобы агент сам
вел кусок проекта. Готовил черновики статей в блог, занимался SEO, чтобы их находили в поисковике и
подхватывал новые темы, чтобы писать новые статьи блога. Ты также описываешь, что хочешь видеть,
а с чего это собрать, ты теперь и знаешь. Собрать такого помощника под свою задачу ты уже можешь,
но довести его до того, чтобы он работал сам по расписанию, без тебя в цикле, это уже отдельная
инженерная глубина. Это вызовы по IP, использовании SDK и так далее. Мы взяли ровно столько,
сколько нужно продуктовому дизайнеру, чтобы собрать рабочую среду и расти в ней. Но сборка
таких систем под продукт, это уже инженерия и в ней можно уходить намного глубже. Итак,
домашнее задание. Как обычно, запустить выполнение этой директивы, дать ему пересобрать твою
среду и сделать скрин твоей среды с скиллами в левой панели и выводом агента в правой о том,
что он там добавил, пересобрал и так далее. Как обычно в Zen Class кидаем этот скриншот и на этом
домашнее задание можно считать выполненным. На этом все, удачи с выполнением домашнего задания
и до встречи в следующем уроке.